Hello. Welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a bit of
a look at the Rust programming language. We're
gonna be doing a few exercises and walking
through everything you need to know to start
writing Rust yourself.
Today, I am joined by Steve Klabik. He
is a
co author of the Rust programming language,
an engineer at Oxford Computers,
and a core team member of the Rust
project itself. Hey, Steve. How are you? Hey.
Doing well. How about yourself? Very well. Thank
you. It's almost at the end of my
day. I believe it's more towards the start
of your day. Spread at noon here. So
Right right smack in the middle. Awesome.
So do you wanna just give us the
quick thirty second version about who you are
and then we'll dive into today's session. Yeah.
Totally. So I've been I've been using Rust
for something like seven or eight years now,
pretty well before Rust one point o. And
I I really love the language, so I
ended up
being one of the first people to write
a tutorial from it
and
kinda just, like, went from there. And now
years later, it's, what I do all the
time. So it's been really cool to watch
a language go from, like, 30 people in
an IRC room to
literally being used by the largest technology companies
in the world to get all sorts of
stuff done.
And, yeah, my focus has traditionally been on,
like, documentation and teaching people and doing stuff
like that. So as you said, I coauthored
the the book, which is the Rust programming
language, which is kind of the the default
book for learning Rust, and I run the
beginner Rust training at Rust conf and do
all that kind of stuff. So
yeah. Totally.
Nice.
Oxide Computer Company is a place that I
work using Rust to do embedded stuff. We're
building some servers.
And
So that's what I'm doing, my my day
job now.
Nice. I like the t shirts. They're pretty
sweet. Yeah. Thanks. I
think
oh, I am so excited by this session
is that Rust just seems to be
everywhere now. Right? Like, I mean, I kept
an eye on it a few years ago,
and you could see it growing in popularity.
I I think everywhere I look though, there's
either people that are writing Rust or people
that just want to write Rust.
And I think it's just so available these
days. I see a lot of really cool
stuff with WebAssembly.
I see a lot of people doing embedded
systems, something that I think you're working on
now. And then even as far as actor
based systems and web based systems, Rust just
seems to be sweeping.
And it seems to be such a popular
choice no matter what the domain is.
Yeah. I I don't know. Can you explain
that? Like Totally. Why is Rust so popular?
I think there's a couple of different things.
So what initially drove me towards Rust was
that
I've I really like programming languages, and I
like learning ones. And I've, like, switched between
languages a lot historically.
And, actually, I primarily was doing Ruby before
I did Rust,
to which I joke that I only programming
languages starting with RU now.
Told that joke in Russia, and I was
like, have to learn Russian too because it's
also RU.
But
no. There's a there's a couple different reasons
why this happening. So so, originally,
Rust is kind of, like, really trying to
focus on the sort of c and c
plus plus use cases, and there hasn't been
a lot of
motion in that corner of the programming language
space. There's been a ton of new languages
appearing that are, like, great for higher level
things, but there hasn't really been anything that's
been, like, a serious competitor in the low
level space for a while. And so that's
why
Mozilla was interested in Rust and why they
sort of sponsored the initial development,
in the early days is because, Firefox's
millions of lines of c plus plus code,
and, you know, you don't wanna visit the
wrong web page and have some JavaScript, like,
own you. So web browsers need to be
super secure,
but you're sort of using these very sharp
and very dangerous tools. And so Mozilla folks
said, like, what if we could have a
a language that's just as powerful as c
and c plus plus, but doesn't have as
many of the significant drawbacks that they do?
And so that was kind of the original
Genesis from there. But as it turns out,
some of the ways in which we we
accomplished that task meant Rod was Rust was,
like, a little more broadly applicable.
And so it's it's sort of been funny,
like, over time, exactly as you said, we've
seen these other use cases kind of, like,
open up as time goes on. And, like,
if you had asked me, would I write
a web service in Rust eight years ago,
I would have said, absolutely not. That would
be ridiculous.
And now there's tons of people who are
doing that even in production, and it's, like,
actually a reasonable choice. So that's been kind
of a surprise to me.
It turns out also that there are other
places, like you mentioned, WebAssembly specifically.
It turns out WebAssembly has a lot more
in common with an embedded device than it
does with a web page in many ways.
And so languages that are really good for
this, like, small constrained environment
also operate really well in that small constrained
environment. So there's been some interesting, like, kinda
cross pollination because of those sort of things.
And then finally, I think another thing that's
sort of driven this kind of renaissance
in this area is as we've moved to
the cloud
and we're built on things like, you know,
CPU time,
languages that have more performance and use less
memory turns into direct,
you know, bottom line cost savings.
You know, back whenever we had our own
servers and we didn't didn't like Kara who's
super ton about, like, scale, when you had
one server and it was running your application,
you were just paying for that server and
that was it. You know, you could use
whatever you wanted as long as it fit
on that server. Now when people are spinning
up thousands of servers by just, you know,
running a small command on AWS,
If you can spin up 500 servers instead
of a thousand servers, you're gonna save yourself
a lot of money. And so there's been
kind of a a renewed interest in languages
that prioritize
efficiency,
because it directly saves you cash.
So that's also, I think, a reason why
people are looking at Rust where maybe that
wouldn't have made as much sense five or
ten years ago.
Yeah. Definitely.
Well, there's a lot of really good points
there. I think that's the best answer I've
ever had to an unplanned question. Like, actually,
quite in-depth. It's in in some ways, I'm
planning for these answers for, like, ten years.
It's not entirely unplanned, but you're definitely right.
They're, like, off the off the cuff. I
was gonna say the last thing is we
tried deliberately to build a really friendly and
welcoming community.
We're not always perfect at that, but, like,
you can get answers from Rust people. And
we've developed a culture where, like, no beginner
question is off limits. Like, we're super happy
to help people, and that's often uncommon in,
especially the lower level, spaces online. And so
we've also sort of developed a big following
because people know and trust that they can
get help with their problems without being, like,
told that they suck. And that's definitely super
useful as well.
I guess, I got something I noticed in
general with not just the Rust community, but
the the Rust tooling. There seems to be
a lot of effort on documentation and even
the compiler error messages and tutorials online. There's
just a lot
I guess because the community is going so
fast, there's a lot of new people and
those are those people are getting a lot
of help along the way, which helps everyone
across this path. Totally.
There's there's one guy specifically, Esteban Cooper, who
works on error messages,
and his kind of approach is that, like
and we'll see, I guess, how that goes
as we actually do this code. But his
idea is that, like, the compiler is, like,
a pair programmer, and it should be helping
you. So you shouldn't just get a message
saying your code is wrong. It should try
to help you actually figure out what you
need to do in response to it. Sometimes
it's very good at that. Sometimes it's not
very good at that. But, like, a concrete
example is Rust has a sync await, kinda
like JavaScript does, but we use a different
syntax than JavaScript does. So we actually changed
the Rust compiler knows how to parse the
JavaScript understanding of async await, specifically to give
you the error message saying, hey. I see
you're trying it like this. Turns out we
actually do it like that instead, so you
should change your code. So that's kind of
an idea about how this tooling can, like,
help people is, you know, by by not
just being like that's an error, but actually
being able to understand, hey. I think you're
trying to do this because you come from
a different language and that's really super cool.
Yeah. I mean, async await is one of
those things. Like, I've written a little bit
of Rust to be dangerous, but every time
I venture down the async path, I just
seem to, like, shoot myself in the foot
so many times. And I I don't think
that's so much the Rust async syntax with
the docs is that I keep trying to
do it with Actix, which doesn't have great
documentation anyway. So Gotcha. Yeah. It's definitely a
moving target in a complicated space for sure.
So Yeah. But it's good fun. So let's
get my screen share then. So we we
have I know we've not done anything in
advance. We've not even had that much of
a conversation.
As far as I know, of us have
looked at the Rustling's examples before, which is
what we're gonna be looking at today. Mhmm.
If people are curious and want to follow
along or do this in their own time,
it's just the Rustling's repository on the Rust
Lang
Gethub organization.
Now it seems to have now I know
the the bet on the rate is painful
to read and I guess I can do
my just know and then turn back out.
But it's got four quizzes and I figured
we try and work our way towards quiz
one. We'll see how we're doing for time
and maybe we'll try and get a few
more bits and pieces done after that. Totally.
What I would suggest to anyone watching, if
there's anything you want us to try and
answer questions on or cover or any sections
we should take a look at, feel free
to drop that in the comments and we'll
do our best to tackle that.
Now, quiz one.
One more. There we go.
Requires us to work with variables and functions,
which makes sense. Probably, it's two of the
most common things we wanna cover. So let's
grab variables first and see what we're dealing
with. So Yeah. To to briefly interject the
way that this Rust things kinda works is
that you you try to compile the examples
and they fail. So this is a not
working program.
And so we'll, like, run it and it'll
tell us, hey. This doesn't work and we
have to fix it to make it work.
So that's kind of the general structure of
this if you haven't heard of Rustlings before.
Nice.
So we run this Rustlings watch command.
My
terminal is acting a bit weird. You know,
I'm just gonna do that here.
Totally.
There we go. Okay. So, yeah, it's trying
to compare variables one and this town is
a variable cannot find value x in that
scope. So let's just take a look at
this. Yeah.
Now if we look at this code, we
can first of all, I mean, we should
cover the basic syntax for anyone that's completely
new to Rust. Totally.
F n, I'm assuming, is a function. Correct.
It's how you declare functions.
There's actually a fun trivia here. So it
used to be in the very old days
that Rust had a rule that no keyword
could be longer than five characters,
and that's because they tended to prefer brevity.
Over time, we relaxed that, but we sort
of kept it where extremely commonly used keynames
or keywords are very short and lesser used
ones are very long. So it turns out
that f n was one that you use
all the time. You define lots of functions,
and, you know, we we decided it's worth
keeping short. So, that's why it's it's, it's
so so short.
We thought about fun or funk, but in
the end, we decided that f n was
was good enough. Yeah.
Yeah. Definitely. Like, I mean, that's that's looks
like c style or c's are ever to
style code. I guess that most people should
find us relatively familiar to them even if
we just even if the keyword is slightly
different. And I guess this is very similar
to go as well, which is also a
c derivative. So
do you wanna explain the exclamation mark here
to people? Yeah. So,
basically, this is print l n, which is
like print line,
again, with a small abbreviation there. But the
exclamation point is because this is a macro.
So we're definitely not gonna get into writing
macros
in this because, honestly, I'm not even that
good at writing macros. But
the the trick is is that macros let
you write code inside of them that is
not normal Rust code, and so depending on
the macro, of course. And so the exclamation
point or sometimes you say bang
means that this is invoking a macro, and
so the stuff that's inside might be a
little weird. Now, specifically, you might say this
doesn't look weird, but it turns out that
Rust actually functions can don't have a variable
number of arguments.
So this,
like,
if we wanted to just do hello,
this,
this would not work in a regular Rust
function because the second version here has one
argument and this the the one on line
13 has two arguments. So we use a
macro. It's because, we want that extra flexibility,
because, as you might imagine,
this is going to print the value of
x by interpolating
the value of x into where the little
curly braces are.
And so we need to be able to,
like, know if you have if you have
three sets of curlies, you want three other
arguments as well as the string. And so
the the print l n macro does a
whole bunch of really fancy stuff to make
all that work and work nicely.
Yeah. Basically, the exclamation point is is used
when you're when you're doing macro stuff.
Very cool. Yeah. Mac metaprogramming or macros is
something that I always struggle with. Like, I've
written a fair amount of a lecture in
my time, and every time I go to
write a macro, I still fall over many,
many times before I get it right. So
Totally.
Luckily, Rust has a, like, culture of external
packages and letting people use them. So I
use macros other people have written all the
time constantly, but so many people have written
so many useful ones that I don't really
find it to be necessary to write my
own very often. So that's kind of like
a a fun interplay of that is that
there's definitely a lot of macros in Rust,
but you almost never need to write them.
You just need to be able to use
them.
Okay.
So let's break down this error message then.
It's telling us the x is not in
scope. Now
it kinda looks like this. This is this
is subtle. Right? I'm I'm not sure if
I understand this, but I'm assuming that this
just maybe wants a let here. Correct. So
to introduce a new variable, you need to
use the let keyword. And that's what this
example is trying to teach you. You can't
just use the name itself. You specifically say
let and then the name of the variable
and then an equals and then the value
of what goes into that variable.
So yeah. Okay. So by adding the let,
if I pop over here,
it compiles and we passed variables one.
Yep. And you can see x has a
value five because it put the five in
where the curly braces were and that's the
the bit that it printed out. So yeah.
Okay. Can we tackle one more thing on
this example then before we move on to
variables two? Absolutely.
We didn't define a type here when we
defined what x is.
Is this the compiler doing type inference and
and doing that for us? Or is there
something else happening here? It's it's specifically the
compiler infers the type of what
it should be.
And so Rust can feel like a dynamically
typed language often,
but is super super statically typed.
One interesting thing about this, and I was
gonna mention this too with the the function
main syntax. So first of all, main is
where Rust program start executing. So you're always
gonna have a main function somewhere, and that's,
like, where things begin.
But
we require you to put types in for
arguments to functions and return types. I'm sure
we're about to get into that in a
second. So the main function has no arguments
and no return. So, therefore, there's no types
written there, but you may see types in
function declarations. And I'm guessing given that that's
where we're going next, we're we're about to
segue into that. But
but yes.
Alright. Let's see. Let's just pop open variables
too then. I think it says so this
paragraph says about this I am done thing.
It's like you gotta remove
when you feel ready for the next exercise,
remove the I am done comment. So I
think that that's
yeah. Totally. We go. Awesome. Cool. Alright.
So I'm done. And then now we have
variables two.
So
our error message is
alright. Okay. So x doesn't have
a type.
Yeah.
So this one is, like, a a little
bit trickier.
So
when it comes to numbers specifically,
there's a lot of different kinds of numbers
in Rust. So we have both signed and
unsigned numbers, which basically means, like, is there
a negative sign? So unsigned numbers can go
from zero to some big number, and signed
numbers go from negative some number to positive
some number.
And so there's there's a lot of them.
I think there's,
like, something like 16 different types or something
like that. Forget. Eight is let's I'll I'll
write them out real quick. We got
U 8, u 6 Oh, can't type.
16,
u 32,
u 64,
and 1 20 8.
And then
so those are the unsigned types. Those can
only be positive. And then there's I eight,
I 16, I 64,
and I one twenty eight. There's also a
couple other
these are only the integer types. So right
there, you can see one, two, three, four,
five. So we got 10 types right there.
There's also floating point numbers and
some other related types. So what's happening here
is
in the earlier example,
we didn't have to write a type because
you weren't doing anything with that variable, and
so Rust just picked the default, which is
u 32.
But here, it's confused because we have this
number 10 and we have this x, and
it's like it's really,
it's really, like, not it's not understanding what's
going on. Now the reason it's not able
to understand I'm gonna delete all these type
names so this actually works.
If you think about this, we never set
a value to x in the first place.
And so
what trying to say, like, they're they're basically,
like, Rust does not have the idea of
null.
So in many languages, if you did something
like this, you make a new variable and
you don't get the value, its value would
be null.
But
here,
we never gave it a value at all.
And so Rust effectively has no idea what
this type is. So it says, hey. I'm
gonna compare this thing. I don't know what
it is to 10. Is that valid? I
have no idea because I don't even know
what x is in the first place.
So that's kinda like what this is complaining
about. Does that make sense? It does. So
based on my naive knowledge then, there's two
ways that I think we can fix this,
and I'm gonna see if you can correct
me on this. No. I don't know. But
if I set this to be an unseen,
and let's just say we do an eight,
does that have a default value that then
that x will become? It does not have
a default value. Let's see what the compiler
says whenever you you do this because I'm
I'm interested in the exact error message, actually.
Yeah. So
use a possibly uninitialized variable x. And so
it's saying, hey. You may have never given
this a value. It can figure it out
most of the time, but it says possibly
because it's it's like, you might have do
it. I just might be I just might
not know. There's some complicated details there. But
the point is is that it's like, hey.
You haven't actually initialized this to a value,
so I'm gonna give you an error.
Now there is
a way that you can opt in to
giving a default value,
And so some types do have a default.
So I'll I'll let me show you that
real fast. Well, actually, let's talk about the
other way first because they're gonna converge
to to one thing, I guess. Okay. So
I'm assuming I mean, I can leave that
type definition there, but I could also just
set it to zero and I could remove
that and that would Right. That would be
okay. Right? Yes. It should be. Let's see
what the compiler says.
It works. Yeah.
So,
so yeah. So now it's, like, looks at
it and says, oh, I have a number
and a number. Neither of them have types,
so they're both U 30 2. So everything
is great. And that totally works. And if
you were to put back the u eight
thing, it would go, oh, then I have
a u eight and something I don't know
what type it is. They must both be
U eights, and that's fine. And it just,
like, figures it out, basically.
The
there so you can opt into the default
value by doing this.
This is maybe slightly more I'm interested to
see if this compiles or not, actually. Let's
let's run this real fast and just check.
It did. It did. So,
yeah. So some types have a default value,
but you have to explicitly ask for them.
So this is saying, there's a thing called
a trait in Rust, which I don't think
we're gonna get to, but they're sort of,
like, interfaces if you've used Go or Java.
Similar kind of idea. And so you can
say, like, please give me the default value
of the default interface for this type. And
so Rust is able to say, oh, u
eight has a default value, which in this
case is zero,
and we'll actually give you that sort of
default. But it's an opt in thing rather
than an opt out thing. And you'll see
this happen a lot with Rust, which is
one of the reasons I think it's a
great question that you asked. It's basically, like,
there's many things where in other languages, something
is the default, and in Rust, it's like,
oh, that's not there. But if you want
it, you can make it happen. And so
in this case,
you have to you have to expressly say,
please give me the default value if you
want one.
I'm
assuming that's just zero. Right? I think I'm
99% sure it's zero, but I don't use
it very often. So who knows? We'll find
out though.
Yeah. Okay. There we go. 0. That would
make sense. I I was gonna be sad
if it wasn't zero.
Okay. Alright. Let's remove our I am done.
And we'll see what we get next. So
variable three with an error.
Oh, no immutability.
Nice. Okay. Yeah.
Oh, let's see if I can articulate the
problem here. So we define access three.
We are
I'm thinking oh, and then trying to reassign
it and that is failing. Mhmm. So
no.
I've written by default
is immutable in Rust. Is that correct, Simon?
Alright. Yes.
So this exercise is what as to introduce
the mute keyword.
Totally.
That
works.
One fun thing, if you remove the mute
and go back to the error that you
got previously
so when I was talking before about how
the compiler tries to help you, you can
see that there, it's got this arrow pointing
to x and it says, hey. Make this
mutable by changing it to mute x. And
so Rust is actually able to say, like,
this may be what you want. And there's
actually a tool called Rust fix that can
take these suggestions and apply them to your
code automatically if you trust the compiler that
much. Every once in a while, it gets
it wrong, but most of the time, it's
pretty good about understanding what's what's going on.
Yeah. So
that's also a thing.
Alright. Let's stick our mute back in then.
Let let say yes,
and then
remove where I am done.
Variables four.
So this one is actually very similar to
number two. So I'm sort of surprised that
they're so similar,
but it's the same. It it is. Right?
It's just a no no value. Right? Yeah.
It's like well, it doesn't have one because
it's like, yeah, there's no there's no no
value. So
it's complaining about I don't know what that
is.
Let's just assume that passes.
Yeah.
Great. So that's the right one. Okay.
So let hold on. I'll read my error
messages first. So expected
string found
integer.
Yes.
Okay. So we define a variable called number.
We print it out, and then
it's trying to be reassigned
and then manipulate it in the next print.
Mhmm. Quite a lot going on there then.
Yeah.
So yes. This is kind of showing you
how once you give a variable some sort
of value, you can't change its type later.
So if this were Ruby or Python or
JavaScript, you know, it's totally fine to have
something be a string and later change it
to a number, and that's, like, not a
big deal. But in Rust, variables have, like,
a type whenever you, you know, make them,
and a type can't change even if the
value can change to something within that similar
type. So yeah.
K. So the fix here is just
Yeah. It I I find it's interesting. I'm
not sure what the fix is they want
you to do here, but
I can show you an interesting fix,
which is to do this. So
so
this will actually work. And this may be
what they're talking about, but I'm not a
% sure.
So what this is actually doing is this
is introducing another variable with the same name.
And
so this is not mutating the original
number three that's a string. This is creating
a new variable with the same name, which
means the old one is no longer accessible,
and so this actually does work.
And this is like a thing that's either
really normal to you or really weird to
you depending on which programming languages you've used
in the past,
frankly.
I'm gonna go with weird. But Yeah.
Yeah. And okay. So that just means we
we remove all references to the former variable
known as number, like, that's Check check it
out like this. Maybe this will help make
it make sense. So
imagine we have a new scope
here. So we have curly braces. Right? So
now
this declares the new variable three, but then
it's gonna go out of scope on this
line. So now here, the old one still
exists. You can kinda think of this like
you have a deck of cards. So you
have, like, the five of clubs, and you
put a new card on top, and it's
like the two of hearts. And then later,
you pull the two of hearts off, and
the five of clubs is still, like, underneath
there.
This would print, like, t h r e
e and then five and then t h
r e e again because it's kinda like
you have this, like, you know, deck of
variables. And then I didn't save it, so
it's like Awesome. I forgot the new thing.
Yeah. Sorry.
There we go. Okay. Yeah. So so now
you can see how it kinda, like, goes
in a scope and then goes out of
scope, and the original value is still there.
It's just the name is, like, no longer
accessible.
Yeah. And it's kinda, like, not super you
know, there's certain situations in which this is
very useful, and it kind of makes the
rest of the world less complicated.
But it can feel weird
if you're not used to it for sure.
It's kind of a semi controversial choice.
Oh, no. Let me remove the I am
done. We'll keep Rust things happening.
K. And then we'll pop open number six.
So here
oh, it's trying to define
a constant,
which
is telling us that we have to provide
a
Type. Type. Yes. And it's actually telling us,
hey. You might wanna make this a 32
digit. Which is the default.
So yeah. So so
similar to how we define variables with let,
we can define constants with const.
The difference is is that we don't infer
the type of constants. We make you put
the type out.
And there's a couple different reasons for this,
but, basically, a lot of it boils down
to
it is local variables. You're usually using them
in one place pretty soon, and so it's,
like, easy to figure out what the type
should be. But constants are used globally in
a lot of places, and they, like, often
become sort of external API. And so you're
required to write the type down on constants
even if you're not on on regular variables.
And constants,
they're not just constant, but they're also kinda,
like, global. So you can see how it's
defined outside of the function. We could use
this number in any of our functions anywhere
as opposed to just in the body of
the function itself.
Alright.
It's always good to understand why these decisions
are made. It makes things a lot a
lot easier to understand.
Totally. I I have often found that when
I get mad about something in programming,
if I learn about why the decision was
made to make it that way, I'm like,
you know, I can see why that choice
was made. And so even though it's annoying
to me, like, I get it and I
get less mad about it. So,
yeah. Well, you're doing a lot of embedded
systems work now. Right? So you're working directly
with Linux syscalls?
But not even with Linux syscalls. Like, we
are writing an operating system. Like, I'm the
one Oh. Building the syscalls.
So yes.
So I have to deal with the hardware
and the decisions the hardware people made and,
like, why does this require, you know, doing
this this way and that kind of thing.
So the same thing, just one level down
like anything.
I hope you kept the e in your
create SIS call though. Yeah.
Totally.
Okay. So
this never onto the functions elements. It's like,
okay. We're gonna understand how Rust functions work.
We can see we've got our main function,
which we're not familiar with, and it's trying
to call a function that hasn't been defined
yet. Mhmm. But I'm assuming we can just
define our new function.
Is is that enough for that to pass?
That should be enough. Let's let's give it
a run.
Done.
So if we can when we don't provide
a return type or even any code within
a function,
what happens there? Is that just a void
type? Or So
sorta kinda. Let's see what happens with functions
two and three, and it'll be a little
easier. I don't wanna, like, get too far
ahead of ourselves,
and I'm assuming that one of these next
examples will sorta get into the details.
Yeah.
This will be a little a little
more helpful. So the the error message let's
let's take a look at the actual error
message. So
there's a couple things going on.
As it says, anonymous parameters oh, interesting.
That's a funny,
not super ideal error message.
But,
basically,
what it's saying here is that numb
is a a parameter, but you haven't given
it a type. So, it's expecting you to
say what the type of numb is. So
I mentioned this before, variables get type inference,
but the arguments to functions don't.
And part of the reason for that is
that there's a couple different things, but the
primary one is that sort of, like, Rust
thinks about the function signature as being, like,
the contract. And so you declare the contract
upfront, and then it checks that the body
fits. So I kind of like to think
about it as, like, the first unit test.
You say, like, I expect there to be
this type. And so if it inferred the
type, you could make a change in the
body and that would change the type of
the function, and then you get, like, weird
bad error messages. And so Rust's attitude with
this is put the types in the function
signatures,
and then you will get nice errors only
in the body of your functions instead of
if can imagine, like, we go back to
the code.
If
if we change the type of the body
here and then this there was, like, a
problem, like, up here on line seven, you
would get an error message about line seven
being wrong when your actual error message would
be, like, you know, your app your problem
would be down here or whatever.
But I said that's the string. We'll see
some sort of message that just says
Yeah. Let's let's see what happens. It's complaining.
Maybe. Yeah. So it expected a string and
found an integer because we're passing an integer
in.
We tell it to expect an integer.
It's happy. Yep.
So this is how you pass arguments, and
it's sort of the same as the
variable syntax except for there's no let. Right?
So you have the name, the colon, and
the type just like we had in variables.
So ends up being the same thing.
Okay. So I'm curious. Like, whenever it's, like,
best and we were getting the error message
Yeah. It told us that we could also
if not using the colon, use at or
the pipe. Like, what would what would those
be? So
it turns out that the syntax is not
actually,
like, a
name colon type.
The syntax is actually pattern colon type.
And so
this gets into some more interesting and complicated
things. But, like, for example, Rust has two
pools. So you could say, like, this won't
work because I'm outside of function body, but
to give you an example of, like, the
syntax. So x equals one two oh, I
hit escape, which is bad.
So here now x would be a two
ball where you have a first element one
and a second element two. Right?
But because this is a pattern,
you can actually do fancier things. So I
could actually say, let x comma y equals
one comma two, and this would assign one
to x and two to y.
So,
so that's like a thing that's there. So
there's actually a whole bunch of fancy things
that you can do in here. And so,
what actually this lets you do is there's
there's some more complicated syntax where you can
put an at and then some more stuff
here or an or and then more stuff
here. And so the error message is, like,
saying, like, you either need the the type
or you need to be doing one of
those fancier things. So you almost never want
to be doing those things, so that's why
the error is, like, slightly misleading.
But it is technically the case that you
could do that if you wanted.
Alright.
Good to know.
So
oh, why It's the next example. You removed
Yeah. That's
silly me. Alright. Okay. Functions functions three.
We have an error message that tells us
expected one argument. This should be nice and
trivial. I'm assuming it just wants us to
to fix that. There we go. Okay.
On functions four.
K. We've got a little bit more code
here. So we got a main function,
setting some integer,
and then trying to calculate It's still price.
So you can actually see the right by
your cursor, there's a little squiggly a little
red squiggly right after the arrow. And so
I think that it actually
it it gives you the error right in
line. So Visual Studio Code has really great
integration
If you install the the Rust Analyzer plug
in like you have, you don't even have
to run them necessarily. It will figure out,
hey. This is I expected a type here.
So that's I wanted to point that out
too before you, you know, went back over.
We could see what the full error is
by looking at the terminal or whatever, but
you can also get those errors in your
thing. Pretty much the same error message. Basically,
the same thing. So yeah. So the way
that you do return types, you have a
little arrow, and then that gives you the
type of whatever you're returning. So in this
case, we wanna take in a price and
then return the discounted price. So we need
to take in an I 32, but also
return an I 32.
Okay. That's it. Right? Yep. There we go.
Finally, we have functions five.
So this is another fun
one. So
it's saying that expected an end oh, okay.
Is this because we don't have a return
keyword?
Yes. So there's two ways to solve this.
There's the, like,
idiomatic and the unidiomatic way. It turns out
that many languages do the what is unidiomatic
in Rust, but you're totally right. Because we
don't have a return keyword,
this is going to multiply two numbers and
then not give you the the value back.
So it's, like, kind of like a no
op. Like, it doesn't do anything. So if
you add return right before the numb asterisk
numb, this should work and everything is great.
So this works. However,
Rust is what's called an expression oriented language,
which means that almost everything evaluates
to some other value. So you can actually
drop the semicolon and the return.
And now we have just num times num
on its own. The the semicolon basically says,
like, hey. I don't care about the return
value of this. I wanna just, like, ignore
it. So, and that's why it's at the
end of almost every line is because, like,
that's kinda, like, how the structure of the
grammar works. So if you do it like
this, which is num times none with no
return, that will evaluate to nine as well
and give you the return value back. And
this is very common in some languages like
Ruby, for example, and totally foreign
if you do see your JavaScript or whatever.
This is another example of where Rust has
taken an influence from a certain style of
programming language that can maybe feel a little
bit awkward if you haven't worked in it.
And this is probably the number one thing
that people who are new to Rust kinda
complain about. So
and part of the reason why is that
when you start getting into things like closures,
this syntax becomes much more normal and regular
and smaller,
and so it ends up being a lot
easier.
But that's kinda jumping ahead, I guess, a
little bit.
So as the the golden rule there that
if you met a semicolon,
it's always an expression, which means it's, like,
kind of always an expression. You can kinda
think of it as, like, expression
exists. And if you put a semicolon on
it, then you don't get the value. You
get an empty tuple, which is these double
parentheses because, nothing in inside. It's like we
had the one and two before.
Just an empty tuple. So
It's kind of a little weird, kind of
a little in the weeds, a little technical.
Honestly, the compiler will tell you when you
get it wrong and you just fix it
one or the other ways. And eventually, you
kinda develop an intuition and you stop worrying
about it.
But yeah.
Alright.
But I think we have now covered everything
for quiz one. Thanks, sir. We could do
quiz one, which I guess would just
confirm that we've learned stuff live. It's basically
just writing the syntax that we've learned in
the previous examples.
Yeah.
Okay. So it's telling me I'm not allowed
to modify. Okay. I have to write the
calculate apple price function. Yep.
Alright.
Take some
price.
Another return value.
Mhmm.
And
I should probably redo what it's supposed to
do.
Oh, it's how many apples I'm buying.
So it's if you have more than 40,
you it only costs 1. Basically, it costs
2 unless you're doing more than 40 in
which it costs 1. So there's, like, a
very small
calculation
there.
Alright. Well, number of apples.
And snake case is the idiomatic Rust approach.
Is that right? In so it's snake case
for variables and function names, and it's camel
case for types.
So you'll see, like, capital s string or
capital v vec.
And that way, can kinda tell at a
glance if it's something is a function or
variable or a type.
And then we return the number of apples
times one or the number of apples.
So
You're close. So
because of the way that you've written this,
the if statement would return into that number
of apples, but it's not gonna, like, return
it from the function entirely. So you have
two
have two ways of doing this. You can
either make the whole body one if expression.
You have two expressions here. Right? You have
the if and then you have the second
thing. So you're gonna do an if else.
That way, the whole body is one if
statement,
or you can use return to return early
and,
yeah,
that that actually will technically work. I think
most people would write it inside the body
of the if instead. So, like, online 27.
Yeah.
So this should work, I think.
Yay. You did it. And the alternative approach
you said there was
to to else here so that I only
have one expression and then Yeah. And then
now both
arms of the if evaluate to a value,
and then the whole thing gets returned. And
so that ends up being the same thing.
Yeah. So this is now one expression in
the body instead of two expressions.
Nice.
Alright. Let's see. What does quiz two want
from us? So this is the
strings. Yeah.
This is definitely one of the things that
always trips me up when I'm
attempting to write Rust, I should say. Totally.
Is that should I mean, what is the
idiomatic way? Should I be using
string, or should I be using string types?
Like, is there a one I should choose
by default? Are there any rules? And that
maybe we could just start by saying what
are the differences between Totally. So for the
background, Rust has sort of
depending on how you answer this question, Rust
either has one or, like, seven string types.
Part of that is because in many languages
with, like, garbage collection and stuff like that,
strings are a little easier. But it turns
out that any sort of variable
width structure is really difficult whenever you're, whenever
you don't have a GC and some other
things. And so,
this is kind of like strings are sort
of the entry point into
going from the absolute beginning. So we've sort
of done stuff that looks the same in
Rust as in basically any language. Strings are
kind of like the usual point where people
start learning a little more about the details
of things. And, honestly, it's so common that
we actually reoriented
the table of contents of the book around
the question of what do you need to
get to to understand strings and then how
to explain strings as early as possible. So
the first three chapters of the book are
kind of all the generic sort of syntax
that we've talked about so far. And then
chapter four is, like, let's get into it
with strings. So
the way you can think about these, these
are the two most core types about strings
in Rust.
The first one, the ampersand str,
if you've done some c or c plus
plus languages like that, you may recognize the
ampersand means it's like a reference.
And the capital s string is sort of
a what we call an own string type.
So sort of the difference is is that
the ampersand str is kind of like a
you're looking at some other string that exists
somewhere, so it's immutable. You can't change anything
about it. The capitalist string means that you
are the one who's in control of the
data of the string, and so that means
you can change it, you can modify it,
you can grow,
and and modify things. And so, that's that's
kinda like when you would use each one
depends on
what, you know, what you're trying to do.
If you wanna change the string itself and
modify it some way, you'd be using capital
s string.
If you just wanna read the value and
you don't care about doing modifications, you would
use you'll use ampersand string.
And one interesting thing that that kinda, like,
comes out of that is it means that
you often see ampersand string as arguments to
a function, and you often see capital s
string as a return type of a function.
So if you think about it, usually, you
take an argument, you don't change it, you
just look at it and do whatever. But
if you're returning something, that often means that
you wanna, like the person who's getting that
back is gonna change it or modify it
in some way or do something like that.
So you can see this exactly on line
12 here. We're returning a capital s string,
but, it turns out the string literals are
ampersand string, and so it's gonna complain that
the types don't make sense. If you if
you run the the compiler,
it should
Oh, I didn't remove my
Oh, yeah. Think it didn't get saved on
variable three dot r s. Oh, yeah. Line
four is I'm not done. Although, it's
a nice coincidence that I had to open
this again, I guess, actually, because we had
a question from someone Oh, cool. I missed
it. For a quiz one. And I think
because this is slightly out of context, I'm
gonna try and guess what they ask.
But does it work with the parenthesis? And
I'm assuming what they're suggesting was
this approach,
but removing these
So those that might be a question. I
don't think that's what they asked, but this
does not work. It's true.
Those are curly braces, not parentheses. The parentheses
are the around number of apples greater than
equal to 40, the the rounded ones on
line 26.
So
yes. And, actually, the compiler will warn you
if you put those parentheses in there because
they are actually not needed in Rust.
And so you can put them if you
want,
but usually people drop them off. So
That's
both both versions of if whichever way they
meant, those are the two answers to those
two questions totally.
Oh, you're right. I don't know why I
thought those were print, but we're good. That
was good to know anyway. Yeah. Yeah. I'm
so used to this in Go that I
now accidentally type or try to do that
in other languages and then always end up
getting frustrated. So it's good that that works.
Yeah. There's actually really interesting history there about
programming languages and grammar and stuff, but we're
getting too far off topic probably, so I
won't get into it. But just the point
is new languages have dropped it because they
require the curly braces. If you don't require
the curly braces, then you need the parentheses
more than if you don't. And so that's
there's there's a whole bunch going on there.
It's actually a pretty interesting question if you're
into languages.
So yeah.
Okay. So this why is that one on
just primitive types? Why did it go to
primitive types? Yeah. Maybe that's because that's the
next one instead of this one. But quest
two said strings,
though.
Oh, that's guess okay. Maybe this is not
a quiz on primitive types. So that's okay.
Maybe that's what it is. Yeah. It's a
quiz. We'll we'll just walk through strings one
and two and then we can double back.
So it looks like we have two options
here then is that and someone has suggested
this in the comment. So SDS says, we
could just can we change the return type
to just be an ampersand string instead of
an uppercase string? Yes. So the answer is
yes, but there's also a small caveat. So
if you try to compile this, it will
actually complain.
Maybe it's not what to run. Right? Maybe.
Yeah. There you go. Right. So it says
expected named lifetime parameter. And so this helps
as if the return type is borrowed, but
there's no value for it to borrow from,
you wanna use the tick static lifetime. This
is very jargon heavy, but the point is,
basically,
you can return the type. But if, if
we go back to the code, I can
sort of, like, show you. So since we're,
like, referencing a string that lives somewhere else,
normally, what would happen is if you have
some sort of, like, say that this took
this took an a string as an argument
too,
then I would say, oh, you wanna return
something that's borrowing from the argument, and so
this would, like, be more normal, but we're
not we have no argument here. And so
Rust needs to know, hey. You're referring to
a string, but I don't know where you're
referring to or what what is going on.
And so there's a special syntax called lifetimes
that, and there's a special lifetime called static.
So the full name of string literals is
actually this, which is ampersand tick static str.
And what that means is that tick static
means that this lives forever,
basically. And so since you have a literal
string, it's never going to, like, be deallocated
from memory or whatever.
Sort of there's a lot of complicatedness
we can get into in theory in there,
but just the point is that Rust will
complain slightly and make you put this. So
this is a valid solution to this problem.
I don't think it's the one that they
wanted to give you because it's a lot
of syntax for a very little reason, honestly.
But it does work in this case.
So just to confirm,
this applying a static live thing to the
string means that for however long our program
runs, the string blue will always be stored
in memory. Right. And that's because it literally
puts the words blue into the binary of
your program, and so it's valid forever because
it's, like, actually part of the, like, literal
text of the thing that is on your
computer that's running.
And if we want you to use the
uppercase string, then I'm assuming it wants us
to do
an actualized access over there.
That should also work just fine.
It turns out that strings implement a lot
of different interfaces. So there's actually, like, six
different ways to write the body of this
function that will all work. This is the
way that I personally prefer to write it.
And so this is what I would write
if I was writing this code.
Okay. Good to know.
And I think there was something important you
were saying you know, when you were explaining
it to different types of thing is that
if you're returning a string from a function,
you probably always wanna use an upper string,
uppercase string that allows it to be modified,
a hard coded string that you can do
and they get away with using an ampersand.
Is that roughly what Toy examples like this,
you often have hard coded strings, but, like,
imagine this is not current favorite color, but
this is, like, load color from config file.
The value in the config file would not
be a literal string. It would be something
we'd be reading from the file and returning.
And so we would want to return the,
like, capital s string where it's, you know,
you may look at it or inspect it
or do whatever later. And so that's usually
you'll want the capital s string when you're
returning things.
Nice.
Okay.
Strings two. Let's see what we got here.
So we're not allowed to change or at
least we're not supposed to be changing definition
of a word. Mhmm.
We are doing an
it's color words.
Okay. So this is
at the wrong type here.
Right.
And
and it's just returning a
billing based on this expression. Okay.
I mean, is that
just that? You could you could do this.
Yes. I don't think this is what you
want they want you to do, but you
can definitely do it. So try run it
and see if this works. I am, like,
99% sure this will be fine. Yeah. Totally.
So that's cool. So we can totally do
this.
However, I think what they wanna do, there's
kind of this joke in in Rust, which
is, like, you put an ampersand on it
is the default, if the compiler yells at
you. So you can convert. So in the
same way, what I'm I said the ampersand
string is like a view into a string
that lives somewhere else. So what you can
do is there on line nine where you're
at, if you make an ampersand word.
So it's similar to how they have the
ampersand stir.
This will kind of this will make an
ampersand stir that refers to the capital s
string, and so this will also work. And
so this is the code that I expect
they would want you to write and what
is more
likely. So this this encapsulates a really common
pattern in Rust, which is where you have
this capitalist string because you've loaded it from
somewhere, but you wanna operate on it in
a way that's,
you know, like, you're just reading the value.
And so this is what I was saying
earlier about how parameters are often ampersand stir.
So all you need to do to convert
the capitalist or string
into a temporary ampersand stir is you just
throw an ampersand on the front of it,
and then that will coerce it appropriately.
Okay. And the reason we wanted that approach
instead of best approach is, I guess, because
of the move semantics as well? Yes. Totally.
So if if I were to print word
down here, this will
yeah.
This would fail to compile because,
as it says, you've you've moved it into
the function. So when you when you pass
a capital s string, you're saying, like, hey.
Here's a color word. This is your string
now. Feel free to do what you want
with it.
And, at the end of the function body,
it will deallocate that string. And so it
will just, like, totally throw away all its
contents.
Whereas
if you use the ampersand version, you're just
passing in a temporary view into that string
instead.
And so,
you know, everything will be peachy keen
afterwards.
Yes. I guess I mean, one of the
nasty habits I seem to have got when
I write some Rust now is to throw
in dot clones.
Yeah. This would also technically work.
What this would just do is copy the
memory, and so this will basically just be
very, I mean, it's five letters. Right? So
it's going to be extremely
slower and use a tiny bit more memory,
like an imperceptible amount. So it's definitely not
a big deal. And if you get your
code to work with the clones, totally super
fine, especially when you're starting out. The important
part is to get your program working.
It does not matter if it's the fastest
possible thing. Like, one kinda interesting pattern is
that a lot of people who are new
to Rust make things harder on themselves than
they have to be. Because once you're given
the power of, like, making it so fast
and small and tiny,
you will, like, want to make it the
case that it is that fast and small
and tiny. And so people will go to
great lengths to avoid typing out a clone
when, like, they could just have their program
working. And, like, this will still be faster
than your Ruby or Python and still use
less memory even though you're making an extra
copy. So, like, don't sweat it when you're
starting. Just, like, throw a clone around. It's,
like, it's totally fine. Not a big deal.
Alright. Well, we'll leave that like that for
now. Well, I don't know if we'll make
it to move semantics, but we'll definitely have
a look anyway. So we got two comments
on this example. So SD is back and
saying,
when we use string from,
is this resource from the heap?
Yeah. So what happens is is the string
will will allocate some memory on the heap,
and then it will copy the green into
the heap afterwards. Yeah. It doesn't it doesn't
necessarily take it from the heap. It puts
it on the heap, but I think that
that's what you were trying to ask. Yes.
And Sev is asking, and this could because
I actually had to stop too. Is there
some magic between the ampersand on the string
that casts that to Yeah. Yeah. This is
a great question because I I was I
was trying to see if no one would
notice. So you've got some sharp viewers.
So technically,
yeah, what what you may notice, if you
think about it in terms of, like, forget
that. Yeah. It does go down. So, if
you think about this, like,
you know, okay. I have a string,
and then I'm gonna close the little terminal
I have because I can't see this well.
And then I put an ampersand on the
front. That makes it a capital ampersand string.
So how do we get a stir out
of this?
And the answer is is that in Rust,
there's an interface called dRef.
And what that means is
dRef.
And so
there's a special way that you can implement
deref
to do coercions. Rust,
generally speaking, does very few coercions implicitly on
its own. This is one of the only
cases in which it will enable a coercion.
And so, basically, what ends up happening here
is that
the the implementation
there's gonna be a lot of syntax here.
So I'm just gonna, like, show you, and
then we'll, we'll, like, not worry about it
because, like, there's gonna be a bunch. But
in the standard library somewhere,
there's some code that looks like this.
I changed. I copied and pasted some some
lines. So
I think it looks like this. I totally
forget. Anyway, this is a whole bunch giant
pile of garbage. The point is is that
it says, like, if you have a string,
you implement d rep for it, and the
type that comes out is this stir. The
reason there's no ampersand there is complicated and
far too advanced right now. It doesn't matter.
But the point is is that, like, there's
this there's this implementation. You can go look
it up if you really wanna know how
it works.
But whenever you have
string d refs to the target of ampersand
stir, that means an ampersand string can turn
into an ampersand stir. And so,
this is just one of those magic coercions,
and
that that, it's like it's like one of
those things where and this is why throwing
ampersand on it is, like, often the solution
to things in Rust because, like, many things
will have this this pattern of, like, there's
the type that is owned and mutable.
There's the type that's viewable and, like, not
changeable, and you implement d rep between them
so you get this nice coercion.
So that's the that's the high level version
of that answer. And you could you could
fill up a whole podcast with just the
details on on specifically how all that works
and, like, a bunch of things. But, yeah,
that's basically basically what it is is Rust
will coerce it, and there's an interface you
can use on your own types if you
wanna implement that coercion.
That's pretty cool. It's it's nice that it's
just using, you know, the different tree implementations,
and there's not just some hardcore compiler magic
that knows kinda what to do there. Like
Yeah. There's a lot of things like this
in Rust where the thing that is like
would normally be compiler magic is hooked into
via some sort of trait. And so you
could implement the trait on your type and
have access to the exact same same magic.
It's very common in a lot of places.
Alright. Let's move on then from there. So
was gonna move us on to primitive
types.
Let's pop that open.
So now we're looking at, oh, billions. Okay.
Yeah. This is very similar to the stuff
we've done before. Sometimes Rustling goes very slow
because it's designed for being a single person
with no help on their own. So it
does a very good job of taking very
small steps. But, you know
so we've we've kind of already covered this,
which would be great practice if, you know,
I wasn't here. But I I think we've
talked about this a bunch, so this should
be pretty easy for you.
Well, why don't we just pick something a
little bit more interesting? Yeah. Sure. We we've
got about,
say, twenty minutes left based Cool. Roughly. So
let's see. What have we got? Let's close
it down. Oh, exercises.
Is there anything that you think would be
fun to go through? I think maybe one
good example next, so we have twenty minutes,
is, like, in the intermediate part is sort
of, like, structs. Because I wanna show you
how you can define your own types in
Rust because that's also a useful sort of
thing.
This is Rust analyzers on my side. It's
got a lot of yeah. My my screen
looks very different than yours. It's kinda funny,
actually. Almost all of the little, like,
things where it says zero implementations on yours
Say, like, missing command on mine. So that's
kind of interesting.
I have to file a bug about the
live code share, etcetera. Yeah. Where's my Rust
Analyzer Revolts, Griggles? Yeah. Yeah. You've got it's
good. So
well, part of it's because
yeah. Anyway
okay. So, let's let's just get into it
rather than talking about bugs in the in
the IDE integration.
So, on line six here, have a struct.
And so
Rust doesn't have classes. It doesn't really do
object oriented programming exactly, but it can feel
like it's sort of you've seen methods already
and stuff like that. So the difference is
that Rust has structs. So, like
okay.
Classes in an object oriented programming have sort
of two things. Right? You have the data
and the behavior, and they go together in
a class. And so Rust kinda says those
are two separate things, so we should separate
them. So instead of instead of classes,
we have structs,
which are purely data, and then we have
functions and methods that are the behavior that
operates on the data. So there's a little
more separation
in Rust than there is in other languages.
So here, we have this struct, color classic
struct,
and there's no data inside of the body
of it. So it's not, like, super useful
because there's there's nothing there. So if we
look at down at the
examples
and, like, what these tests are kinda doing,
we can sort of see what they want
us to do.
So
let's see. So
it's gonna complain about
green doesn't exist
and then
the name being this
classic struct thing. So
I look up here. Yeah. Color classic struct.
Interesting.
So I don't know why it's referring to
these as classic c structs. Maybe we'll figure
it out as we type stuff here. But
down here on line 22,
where it says let green equals. So the
thing it's saying is, like,
we have all this color classic struct, right,
from above.
And
so this would be how we would, like,
instantiate it as we said the name and
then the curly braces.
But it's gonna complain because we don't have
a name and we don't have a hex.
So you can see on line twenty six
and twenty seven, use green dot name and
green dot hex to get sort of these,
like, values.
So what we'd want to do here is
we would wanna say name
is
green
and hex
is
bound zero zero
f f zero zero.
And so this, like,
this would work from declaring the body of
it, but it's gonna give us an error
about defining the struct up above.
So let's,
let's briefly jump up there, and we'll also
check those out. So color classic struct up
here. We would have,
name is a static str,
and
hex is also a static str. So I
think that this text will now
test will now work.
Let's double check that's true before we talk
about what the syntax looks like.
So this is complaining about 38. So this
is the other test. So think we're good.
Cool.
So yeah. So with the struct, if we
look up here at line, eight and nine,
very just much like we had the name
colon type with variables and with function arguments
is the exact same thing in struct. So
here, this color classic struct ends up being,
as two sort of data types inside of
it. So one string with the name and
one string with the, hex decimal value of
what the color is. I'm guessing this is
kinda like CSS colors or RGB values in
general where it's got some sort of name
associated than the actual type. And so
that's how you declare it. It's like a
struct, name of the struct,
curlies,
and then the same name and value pairs.
One thing you'll notice
is that there's a trailing comma here on
line nine. So Rust has support for trailing
commas, and, so that's really, really nice. Every
time I go back to JavaScript or JSON
and I can't put a trailing comma, I
get a little sad.
But, you know, this is like a stylistic
preference. You don't have to put one there.
If you leave it off, that that will
work. But, it's usually people put them in
because that's the preferred style of things.
So in the same way that's how you
declare a struct, we when we instantiate one,
you can see on line 24 to 27,
it's almost the exact same thing as when
we, like, assign a variable to value
except where, you know, we're let green equals
and then struct. And then inside of it,
we have the name as green and the
hex is that value. And so the the
syntax mirrors the kind of declaration syntax in
the same way. Okay. Did you use a
a static livestream string because of these assertions,
or would that just be, like, common practice
to not use this I use it because
of the assertions.
Usually,
in the same way that, like, if you
return a value, you will often return a
capital s string.
Most of the time in a in a
real world, Chuck, like, imagine again, like, I
always go to the config file example because
I think that's very intuitive.
So
if we were gonna be loading this color
from a file, we wouldn't have a string
literal, and so I would use a capital
s string.
And so I I purely just did that
because there are string literals in this text.
But normally,
I would I would sort of default personally
to to making this a string and making
this a string.
And that will, like, work. It just means
that this is gonna get a little weirder.
We'd wanna do a string from
down here and then same thing here.
And then finally, I think this might this
might compare or might not. We may have
to toss the ampersand on it to get
it to work.
But, like, this would be what the string
from version would look like. This looks a
little grosser in the tests, but it's more
likely to reflect
what, like, actual real world code would look
like.
Is there a macro for creating a string
that simplifies the syntax? The thing is is
that, like, someone did release a crate, like,
a crates or packages in Rust. So somebody
did release something that would let you type
s bang.
But, like, is it really worth getting a
whole external package just to eliminate, like, five
or six characters here? Like, generally not.
It's just like it's like it's it's one
of those things that it's like, it is
slightly unfortunate that's a little long, but it's
also not long enough to be so much
of a pain that you, like, resort to
something like a macro to fix it.
There may be someday,
maybe string literals will just coerce into capital
s string automatically. There's definitely some people that
want that. There's some people also that because
of that heap allocation,
there would be upset that we'd be doing
heap allocation implicitly.
And so
there's kind of a a battle over whether
it's a good idea or not.
Okay.
Let's remove that. So there was a a
question. I was gonna keep the layer, but
because you're kinda talking about battles between what
people wanna see, maybe it kinda nicely
segues in. But we had a question that
said,
Rust is very readable and enjoyable.
Or what does the team take into mind
when it's trying to add new features and
it's referencing
things like c plus plus 20?
Yeah. So
I I think the interesting thing about the
wording of this specifically is, like, to make
it complicated and ugly, or are they trying
to say to not make it complicated? Yeah.
Okay. Cool. There we go. Yeah. Awesome. So
one kinda, like, interesting thing about Rust and
its syntax is a lot of people hate
it, and a lot of people don't understand
why other people hate it. And the reason
is is that Rust really draws inspiration
from a lot of other languages.
So almost nothing in Rust is actually new.
Many of the things the the name specifically
is, like, evoking the idea of a well
worn tool, like something that's been around for
a long time.
And so,
like,
the
a lot of the syntaxes are drawn from,
like, several disparate
sources.
So, like, you have some stuff that's a
little c inspired,
some stuff that's a little, like, ML or
OCaml inspired, some stuff that's a little Ruby
inspired, some stuff that's a little Python inspired.
And that means if you, like, if you
don't have the particular
background,
it can feel really, really strange.
But if you do, it feels really, really
normal. And that leads to a lot of
areas in which, like, people
will kinda be like, you know, why is
it written like this? Because, like, no language
is these are like this. And they're like,
well, if you've programmed an OCaml before, actually,
this is the exact same syntax.
And so,
you know, or whatever. And so there's there's
definitely sort of kinda, like, fruitful,
arguments to be had.
I think the thing is is that,
specifically, referring c plus plus one of the
things that's a challenge for c plus plus
is that it originally
was very much, like, an object oriented language
that was, like, very much designed in the
late nineties when it was first released.
And then over the last, like, fifteen years,
they've tried to morph it into sort of,
like, a more functional
ish language.
And so when you
it's kinda like trying to change the engine
on a car while you're driving down the
highway. Like, you can do it, but it's,
like, very complicated,
and there's a lot of constraints on the
problem and, like, you know, you've got all
these things going on. And so I would
say the number one thing that we have
in Rust to make it feel more simple
is purely that we started so much later,
and we haven't gone through that process of,
like, let's mutate it into something else entirely
means that there's a lot less weird corner
cases because we we haven't, like, done that
make of a drastic change. And so I
think the number one thing that we can
do to make sure that Rust does not
mutate into something like that is basically to
say
they're like, we're never gonna like, go ahead
and make a new language that replaces Rust
someday rather than trying to turn Rust into
a totally different language incrementally over time.
So that's kind of,
I think that's sort of, like, the key
to it. It's, like, making sure that the
bits stay orthogonal
and that we're not trying to, like, change
the core nature of what Rust is over
time.
There are good reasons why the c plus
folks are doing what they're doing, and and
kinda like that's one of the reasons why
it's still maintained its position of dominance for
so long. So I don't wanna say that
that approach is wrong either, but I think
that we're kind of more, like, in the
interest of, like, we're gonna keep the core
Rust the same way it is. And, like,
maybe another better language will come along someday,
and that's just kind of the natural way
of the world. So it'll it's fine if
we let that happen.
Nice. Cool.
Okay. So shall we I think the other
example in this file is to take a
look at a tuple based
struct. Mhmm.
Do you want to do that or will
we look at yeah. You can do that
real fast because it's not too long. So
in the same way that I talked briefly
about tuples before with, like, let x equals
one two. So this is, an anonymous tuple.
Like, there's no name. You can also declare,
like, a struct that looks like a tuple.
So what you put here is string string.
And so
you can kinda see how it looks sort
of similar, but it's just the type, no
name, and then the type. And so
that means that down here,
it would say, let green equals
color tuple struct,
and then that would be string from
green
and
string
from
pound o o f f o o.
And so this kinda looks more similar to
a tuple, but the name
it's got a name to it instead of
it being anonymous. And so the way that
you access we don't have names. You access
them by numbers. So dot zero and dot
one would give you green and zero f
zero zero because we haven't done the name.
And so, like, under the hood, this operates
the exact same way.
Just like sometimes one or the other feels
more natural in a given situation.
And so, you know, if you have something
that's very simple and small, like, if you
have a point, you know, maybe you don't
wanna go the whole x y z, maybe
just like zero one two is, like, good
enough or whatever. So tuples tend to be
good in very simple circumstances,
and giving things names tend to be useful
when you have something that's a little more
complicated.
Nice. Okay. And
are you do you know what the final
one is about? The unit The final one's
unit struct is you could have a a
a struct that has no data at all.
And so this is called a unit struct.
And so to do that, you just say
let unit struct
equals unit struct,
and
it just exists. There there are some reasons
why this is useful
if you want,
but we probably should since we have limited
time, I don't wanna get super into it.
But just like the point is is that,
you know, you can have any number of
things you want, including zero things.
So
yeah.
Alright. I'll I'll pretend I'll know what that
one's for then. Okay. Totally. It's fine.
Okay. So do wanna do struct two, or
do you wanna jump into something else? Let's
let's briefly
let's not do struct two because this is
going to some other things. Let's check out
struct three real fast because I wanna see
if
right. So this is gonna cover methods, which
is, I think, gonna be interesting. We can
just go over it really briefly. You don't
have to go into all the details. But
point is, like I said, we have this
separation between the data and the behavior. So
here we have our struck package, which has
a country, it's a string, and recipient country,
it's a string, and then a weight is
I 32.
So this is just purely the data. We
use the import keyword to declare an implementation
of package. So this is saying, like, this
is gonna be all the methods that are
involved.
And so,
here we have three methods. One is new,
one is is international, and one is get
fees. You can kinda see the, some of
the versions of this index here. So this
is what would be called a static method
in other languages. We just call it a
a associated
function in Rust.
Details don't really matter. The point is is
that this would take three arguments, the country,
the recipient country, the weight in grams, and
we'll return a package. And so you would,
like, you know, return the value by creating
this struct. So, this because it gets declared
down
here. So package colon colon new is how
you'd invoke it, and you'd be able to
pass in those three things, and you would
get a package back.
If you wanted a method that lets you
do, like, method syntax like foo dot bar,
here, you would take a the first argument
is this self argument.
So it's very similar to self and JavaScript
or Ruby or Python. We're explicit about it
like Python rather than implicit about it like
Ruby. So the the first argument being self
means that this would be a method. So
if we had, say, a package of some
kinds,
then we could say p dot is international,
and that gives you that method to call
to next. And so this gives you Rust
sort of like an o o kind of,
like, feel because you have these methods, but
it's a little cleaner and that your data
and your behavior are cleanly separated as opposed
to being declared in all of one thing.
And in this example, you might say, like,
that's not super useful because you just declare
both of them anyway. That's totally true. Part
of it is because sometimes you only have
data until you just have structs. And so
rather than having two separate concepts, a struct
and a class, you just have one. Everything
is a struct. Sometimes you have methods. Sometimes
you don't have methods, and that feels a
little cleaner.
Also, it's because you can declare methods on
other people's structs if you want.
And there's some interesting rules about those details
there, but by splitting them up into two
separate things, you get that control over, like,
sometimes you just have data, sometimes you have
both, sometimes you put your own methods on
someone else's data.
And so
that's kinda like how all that stuff sorta
works. So you kinda get this o o
ish feel without exactly being
o o,
if that'll make sense. Seems very familiar to
the way that the goal works as well
with Definitely. Go is very similar in this
regard for sure.
And,
traits are what we call interfaces in Go.
So that has a very similar syntax where
you say, emple
trait for package instead of just emple package,
and that's how you'd implement an interface. And
it feels very similar where you would take
interfaces as arguments and, you know, then you
can pass in any structure that implements the
interface and do all that kind of thing.
Nice. Okay.
I think we'll leave it there rather than
trying to rush through anything else in a
in a in a matter of a few
minutes. So
let's remove the screen. If anyone has any
questions, feel free. We'll give you a minute
to drop them into the chat, and we
can just quickly talk for a second. Yeah.
So,
you know, I think
Rust should hopefully feel familiar enough to people
that come from other sea based languages. You
know, there are a few quirks that have
to be learned as I'm sure with all
languages for sure. Yeah. And we've got an
example here of Rustlings, and obviously, you've got
your book, the Rust programming book. Are there
any other resources you would recommend for people
to check out? Definitely. So we have
there's multiple discords that you can join for
getting help in a live chat environment as
opposed to, you know, posting things. There's also
the user forum at users.rustlang.org
where you can ask questions,
if you prefer a forum to a Discord.
And those are both really great resources for
getting going. Other one I would say, and
this kind of an interesting trick is there's
been a lot of people who learn Rust
to try it once and get frustrated and
say, this doesn't make any sense to me.
And then they leave for six months, and
they come back and they try it again.
And they're like, this makes perfect sense. Why
did I get frustrated the first time? And
so,
you know, you should give Rust a try.
And if if it's not for you, that's
totally fine. Maybe it never will be. But
also, you know, just try giving it a
while and coming back. Sometimes
I haven't figured out, like, this is, like,
really if I could figure out what it
is that happens in those months and, like,
get people to understand it immediately, like, I
would do it. But sometimes you just need
to, like, take a step away. It's kinda
like that old programmer advice of, like, go
on a walk or take a shower or
do something else and, like, eventually the answer
kinda comes to you. We found that that
really happens with learning Rust a lot. Like,
people will try it, be like, this is
too hard. I don't understand anything. I'm gonna
quit. And then they come back and they're
like, this makes sense. And sometimes it takes
a couple tries. We've had people say, oh,
yeah. Had to give it three or four
tries before it made sense, but now it
makes perfect sense.
And so so yeah. I don't know. But
that's also the other bit of advice I
would give you is take advantage of the
fact that the community exists and loves answering
questions.
Please post questions and get help if you
want. And, you know, if you don't like
Rust, that's totally fine. Maybe someday you'll like
better. Maybe maybe not. Like, there's lots of
programming languages when they have so much time.
So, you know, it's it's cool.
Yeah. I think that's one of my problems
is that I'm too busy playing with random
esoteric languages instead of actually building anything useful
in one language. Totally. Yeah. Jump in between.
There's just too many good things out there.
Know, there's Rust that I wanna get better
at. There's pony that I wanna get better
at. There's zigs that I wanna get better
at. And I'm just like, I wanna play
with all these things.
It's definitely not enough time in the day.
No. No. Definitely not.
Alright. So we got a couple of things
here. SD said lovely session. Thank you very
Rod
asked a question which I'll rephrase slightly.
Yeah. Has the future of Rust secure with
the recently offset Mozilla?
Yeah. So there is about 200 people that
work on Rust in general. And at the
time of the Mozilla layoffs, like, before the
layoffs happened, only four or five of those
people were employed by Mozilla. So
I it's always tricky to answer this question
because those are my friends and former colleagues.
And so I don't wanna say they don't
matter because they do matter because they are
wonderful people and do a lot of work
in Rust. But at the same time, they're
a small number of a large group of
people, and so
the overall movement of Rust is not really
affected by the Mozilla layoffs. Additionally,
you'll have seen and you will see in
the future more and more companies
picking up, getting into Rust development. So the
big announcement in the last week is Amazon
is, like, explicitly hiring a bunch of people
to work on Rust itself. And so we're
seeing other companies pick up where Mozilla left
off even though, like, as I said before,
most of the Rust development was volunteer in
the first place. So
it it affects us in the sense that,
you know, some people have had to shift
around and some people still work on Rust,
but only in a spare time capacity instead
of a full time one like they used
to.
And some people have just found jobs other
places working on Rust. And so,
you know but definitely, like, the future is
bright and the situation with Mozilla is pretty
independent from the situation of Rust these days.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I I can't add any
more flavor to that other than what you
have said. But I I can say from
the cloud native perspective, which is where my,
you know as the community I'm most involved
in, is all these companies are now adopting
Rust for all
sorts of crazy technology.
And I think there's definitely enough
enough people contribute in in that space that
Rust would definitely have a future regardless of
what happens in this area. And I also
foundation is maybe what you're about to say.
The other part I didn't say is we're
working on starting a Rust foundation,
and so you'll hear some news about that
in the coming months. And so that's also
kind of,
you know, a part of that future too.
Yeah. All sorts of things going on there.
And there was news last week about several
being handed over to the Linux Foundation, which
I'm sure are are probably a key component
of the Rust Foundation work too, hopefully. So
we'll see.
I wouldn't be worried.
So Rod said, thank you.
And finally, I'll finish with SD saying, hey,
Steve, you need to come back so we
can do intermediate Rust. Sure. Yeah. Sounds good.
I wouldn't make him commit on air. Don't
sorry. But we'll speak afterwards.
Regardless of Steve's availability, I do plan on
doing more Rust content and hopefully Steve can
be a part of that too.
Thank you very much for your time today.
That was that was awesome. I think, you
know, we man hopefully covered enough of the
basics that people can get started. If you've
tried it before, definitely give it another try.
As we said, you know, sometimes you just
have to try it twice like olives. Totally.
And I hope you have a great rest
of your day. Thank you again for joining
me and I'll speak to soon. Yeah. You
too. Thanks for having me. Yeah. Thanks a
lot. Bye.